if you meet someone with tremendous
amount of tattoos almost always they
have high anxiety so people who modify
the body a lot whether it be tattoos all
over a lot of piercings very high
likelihood they have tremendously high
levels of anxiety you meet a dude who
acts tough usually has high anxiety my
dad had NPD narcissistic personality
disorder if I know you have NPD I know
you almost always have low anxiety if
you're a woman there's certain questions
you'll know that women have border Li
personality disorder women have it about
four times more than men men are more
likely to be psychopathic women are more
likely to have BPD men call women
psychos it's such a misnomer you'll
almost never meet a psycho woman a
practical example of psychopathy is the
ability to kill a stranger women don't
kill strangers they have a list of like
the last 1,000 Sy kills it was like six
women 994 men there's patterns some of
the magic trick of reading people is
just understanding the science